[Applaudissements]
pour les conservateurs albertin c'est
une page qui se tourne
la fin de la tumultueuse à RDC Kenny
marquée par la pandémie et les
déchirements internes sur les
restrictions sanitaires
pour le consommateur uni leur est
maintenant au choix qui deviendra le
prochain chef et prochain Premier
ministre de la liberté
progressiste centriste populiste urbain
ou ruraux avec cette candidats si tout
le spectre conservateur qui représenté
dans la course
une course de milliers non pas par des
enjeux classiques comme l'économie et la
santé ou l'éducation
mais plutôt par le sort de la province
dans le pays et c'est la favorite
présumée de la course qui vole le plus
loin à ce chapitre
avec sa loi sur la souveraineté Daniel
Smith propose une rupture claire avec
Ottawa si elle emporte plus question de
faire appliquer un Alberta à tes lois
fédérales notamment en matière
d'environnement qui serait considéré
comme contraire aux intérêts de la
provinceur
une idée radicale dénoncée par des
constitutionnalistes et les autres
candidats mais qui séduit beaucoup la
base militante du parti
création d'un fonds de pension malbertin
ou d'une nouvelle police provinciale ou
déclenchement de négociation
constitutionnelle les deux autres
favoris de cette course Brian Jean
et tu avais stays ancien ministre des
Finances joue eux aussi la carte de
l'autonomie
davantage la proche québécoise du
fédéralisme
si le sujet est omniprésent dans la
course c'est surtout que la règle
demande un vote accorde énormément de
poids aux militants des membres qui se
trouvent majoritairement en milieu rural
rappelle ce consultent en affaires
publiques la réalité alberten dirige un
certain point l'agent d'or du parti ces
jours-ci particulièrement sur les
questions d'autonomie et de
d'indépendance à l'intérieur du Canada
inflation santé ou éducation les
préoccupations des albertés moyennes ne
sont pourtant pas différentes des autres
Canadiens la distorsion entre ce que
veut la base du Parti conservateur uni
les populations générales n'a jamais été
aussi grande croisée de sondeuse
[Applaudissements]
cette course à la succession de Jason
Kenny doit en principe mettre fin aux
divisions dans la famille conservatrice
mais les débats entourant la loi sur la
souveraineté anti-sepoint acrimonieux
qu'il est difficile d'imaginer que
dianiosmitt soit l'unanimité si elle
gagne
mosters
qui vont au-delà de sa base pour
plus grande audience d'albertin la
dernière année a été dit plus
tumultueuse pour le mouvement
conservateur albertin rien indique que
les prochains mois seront de tout repos
pour le ou la successeur de Jason Kenny